[Musica]
[Applauso]
Allora il mio intervento si chiama in un
modo curioso il coraggio di vivere il
XXI secolo la curiosità nasce
fondamentalmente da una cosa cioè che
coraggio devi avere per vivere nel XXI
secolo quindi sembrerebbe quasi una cosa
una cosa banale e fatemi iniziare
proprio con le cose banali Cioè se io
fossi in questo momento un Meme potrei
dire che sono il io sono un cittadino
semplice del XXI secolo la mattina io mi
alzo sentendo Alexa che mette la musica
musica classica perché non mi va di
alzarmi in maniera piuttosto traumatica
dopodiché le urlo a Alexa basta e le
ovviamente comincia a stare in silenzio
quella che vedete non è una non è una
stock foto Questa è proprio diciamo così
il mio punto di vista del da parte del
mio letto con uno zoom però e cosa vedo
io la mattina appena mi alzo
Dopodiché durante la giornata se mi
capita di stare in casa se preparo le
lezioni se sto facendo magari sto
leggendo dei libri oppure sto bagagli
facendo delle telefonate delle Call con
dei colleghi per progettare ricerche
cioè si sente un rumore di sottofondo
che che questo robottino che va in giro
per casa e che magari provando a non
inceppare verso la come si vede la
vecchia coperta che mi regalò mia nonna
Quando andai all'università cercava di
pulire diciamo così un po' casa cercando
di assorbire Io sono allergico alla
polvere e quindi ovviamente cerco di
fare di non farlo io ma di farglielo
fare alle macchine Dopodiché magari
durante la giornata Ho voglia di
staccare Ho voglia di magari di perdere
un po' di tempo no nel senso non mi va
sempre di fare cose intelligenti e
interessanti ed essere presenti sui
social mi ha pure di come si dice di di
scherzare di ironizzare e vanno su Tik
Tok ovviamente il mio Tik Tok non è
principalmente di balletti un pochettino
più palloso Però sicuramente è un
momento di intrattenimento dopodiché la
sera finalmente
sono tranquillo fa tutto quello che
dovevo fare Mi sento riposato magari
oppure mangiare eccetera eccetera mi
siedo davanti alla televisione e
al lancio un servizio di streaming e mi
faccio diciamo così orientare sui miei
sui miei gusti Allora cos'è che è
curioso di tutto questo di cui tutto
questo contesto in realtà non ho fatto
non ho detto niente di particolare Ho
parlato di
spolverare ho parlato di cazzeggiare ho
parlato di diciamo così di svegliarmi la
mattina con un orologio piuttosto
rumoroso
però La cosa curiosa è che se noi la
vediamo queste cose in prospettiva ci
accorgiamo che in realtà il ventunesimo
secolo cioè il secolo che stiamo vivendo
è un po' tanto diverso dal ventesimo
secolo quindi la domanda che ci dobbiamo
porre è cos'è cambiato nel ventunesimo
secolo Allora è cambiato tutto
assolutamente tutto ma fondamentalmente
sono cambiate tre cose in particolare
Cominciamo con la prima
noi interagiamo sempre più spesso con
dispositivi che scelgono e che decidono
Questa è una cosa assolutamente nuova
assolutamente interessante assolutamente
innovativa Cioè fino a qualche tempo fa
nel ventesimo secolo il frigorifero non
ti diceva niente la macchina stava
tranquilla per i cavoli suoi e le
caffettiere non ti do tanti suggerivano
cosa dovevi fare né tantomeno lo
facevano alla televisione o le
programmazioni cinematografiche in
realtà Invece noi Adesso vediamo in un
mondo di oggetti tecnologici Che
selezionano dati elaborano informazioni
e suggeriscono contenuti
per esempio Alexa decide cosa farmi
ascoltare io è vero che le dico Alexa
Domani mattina svegliami a quest'ora con
la musica classica ma è lei che decide
quale brano di Bach mettere o quale o
quale Sweet handel farmi ascoltare
un'altra cosa per esempio che è vero che
io vado sui social per cercare
informazioni per per divertirmi ma in
realtà io sono all'interno di un
processo che è stato già determinato gli
algoritmi cioè i social decidono non
solo con quale contenuti interagire ma
anche con quali persone della mia rete
di contatti interagire E da questo punto
di vista Social sono molto banali Cioè
più
inneschi relazioni con le persone da
atleti di contatti più il social
interpreterà questa informazione come
Allora tu sei più amico del signor a e
non del signor B e ti farò quindi più
vedere contenuti via invece che di B
anche se B Comunque il mio carissimo
amico mi scrive meno sui social
Dopodiché per esempio Netflix mi farà
vedere cosa cosa mi verrà dei
suggerimenti ma non sono suggerimenti
casuali e la profilazione dei miei
comportamenti di appassionato di cinema
di cinefilo e anche appassionato di
anime e di serie televisive
questa caratteristica fa sì che noi
viviamo in un contesto molto più
complesso del XX secolo perché le
tecnologie del ventunesimo secolo dato
che raccolgono informazioni elaborano
informazioni e decidono al posto nostro
non sono più tecnologie sono soggetti
sociali
che posseggono una forma di arbitrio un
arbitrio ovviamente computazionale è
roba informatica non ancora libero e non
ancora consapevole
per adesso
il secondo tassello da prendere in
considerazione viviamo in spazi
sintetici analogico digitali Che vuol
dire vivere uno spazio sintetico
analogico digitale
poniamo la cosa proprio che ci accomuna
tutti quanti siamo a cena con degli
amici magari non tutti li conosciamo
bene comunque una cosa che facciamo è
che noi come se fossimo delle pistole le
mettiamo tutti sul tavolo i cellulari
soprattutto noi uomini che magari non
stiamo portando già che non stiamo
portando non stiamo portando degli
indumenti Ma le signore sono pronto più
diciamo così eleganti magari nasconde le
cellule all'interno delle borse quello
che è interessante è che non è solamente
un aggeggio che hai sul tavolo che non
sai mai se mettere dal lato del coltello
o dal lato della forchetta la cosa
interessante che in realtà nel momento
in cui tu metti questo telefonino sul
sul tavolo che magari lo usi per fare
vedere un video divertente alla persona
che ti sta accanto per fare una foto
tutti insieme tutta roba assolutamente
legittima In realtà noi non siamo solo a
cena ma siamo a cena con gli amici e
siamo
contemporaneamente sui social siamo in
due posti diversi siamo ubiqui in quel
momento un altro caso che magari è stato
caratteristico del periodo della del
lockdown Almeno questo che quello che mi
ha caratterizzato Il mio periodo di
lockdown io durante i lockdown gli
facevo lezione e quindi lavoravo a casa
ma faceva lezione fondamentalmente in
streaming collegato con Le piattaforme
digitali
Questa è una cosa che accomuna
moltissimi di noi quando noi siamo a
casa molto spesso è vero che siamo nel
nostro studio variamente declinato i
nostri libri le nostre robe Ma in realtà
siamo anche al lavoro Siamo anche in
relazione con altri colleghi magari
siamo anche in maniera delocalizzata
scambiandoci informazioni contenuti con
a tutta la nostra rete di contatti Siamo
anche in questo caso ubiqui in uno
spazio fisico con delle connotazioni
digitali
facciamo la cosa più banale non so
quanti di voi sono appassionati di
videogiochi Io sono ancora un video
giocatore molto diciamo così diciamo non
sono proprio un nerd Gamer però sono
ancora un appassionato di videogiochi è
una cosa che mi che mi sconvolge tanto
ogni volta che finisco una partita a
qualche videogioco di quelli che mi
appassionano tanto che mi rubano tante
ore ai film che non vedono la sera e che
quindi faccio sempre più tardi la notte
e che in realtà è vero che sono nel
salotto della della mia della mia casa
ma in quel momento sono anche in
un'arena globale dove sto giocando con
altre persone con dei giochi
con dei giochi di ruolo quando dove tu
io magari sto in quel momento sto
interpretando un supereroe però mi
collaboro con altre persone come me sono
supereroi ma da altri punti del mondo
Quindi anche in questo caso sto video
giocando ma mi trovo sia in un salotto
di casa mia che in Arena globale in uno
spazio sociale globale
Questo vuol dire che lo spazio sociale
non è più definito dalle mura delle
architetture fisiche o meglio viene
definito dalle pareti delle stanze
virtuali stiamo diventando grazie alle
tecnologie digitali sempre più liberi
dal cemento ma si passa da un vincolo a
un altro ma sempre più vincolato degli
algoritmi c'è un terzo elemento che
rende diverso il l'epoca contemporanea
volenti o nolenti siamo diventati degli
Cyborg ovviamente c'è chi declina questo
concetto in maniera metaforica perché
ovviamente quella del Cyborg c'è un di
un organismo cibernetico quindi in parte
umana in parte tecnologica sicuramente
una metafora figlio della fantascienza
Ma ci sono altre persone che questo tipo
di rapporto ce l'hanno molto più fisico
penso per esempio a malachia e cronache
come le persone che soffrono di diabete
che hanno molto spesso sempre più spesso
dei sensori sul proprio braccio con cui
controllo il diabete tramite telefonini
in un modo o nell'altro stiamo
diventando Cyborg O comunque lo siamo
già diventati questo cosa vuol dire
Allora il telefonino è diventato la
scatola nera della nostra vita questa
non è una frase mia la frase di un film
tra l'altro un film tradotto e portati
in tutto il mondo di Paolo genovese del
2016 perfetti sconosciuti la storia del
film Non so se la conoscete Praticamente
sono questi amici che si ritrovano a
cena tutti insieme a un certo punto per
gioco e decidono Ognuno di scambiarsi il
cellulare quindi venendo a sapere delle
cose degli aula dell'altro che sarebbe
stato opportuno che sarebbero rimaste
private il telefonino si comporta come
una vera e propria scatola nera così
come le scatole nere degli aerei vengono
essere aperte come delle scatole di
Pandora per capire cosa è successo in
caso di incidente invece le scatole nere
i nostri telefonini e sono le tracce di
quello che facciamo durante il giorno le
nostre telefonate i nostri messaggi i
nostri tradimenti le nostre foto le
nostre chat e le nostre relazioni
questo fa sì che già il telefonino non è
una tecnologia ma è il nostro doppio il
gangher come dicono i tedeschi cioè il
nostro doppio
se ciò non bastasse prendiamo un'altra
un'altra tecnologia molto diciamo così
molto diffusa adesso soprattutto per gli
appassionati per gli efficientisti o
ancora usavo orologi vecchi perché non
riesco ancorare le notifiche legate al
polso gli Smartwatch gli Smartwatch per
esempio perché sono diventati delle
delle cose che hanno a che fare più con
la dimensione del Cyborg e non credo
delle tecnologie perché gli Smartwatch
sono in realtà delle estensioni di
Internet wearable cioè indossate sul
nostro corpo più intime di un telefono
ma più distaccati di una rete internet
questo fa sì che noi facciamo non siamo
più delle persone isolate come degli
individui ma siamo sempre delle nodi di
una rete che può essere
contemporaneamente sociale o tecnologica
o in alcuni casi solo tecnologica
un'altra situazione Vi è mai capitato di
mandare via WhatsApp un messaggio vocale
anche se non lo volevate fare e iniziate
tutti con la frase Scusami se ti sto
mandando un messaggio vocale e comincia
poi tutto bla bla bla bla bla bla Già il
fatto che noi ci dobbiamo scusare per
mandare un messaggio vocale in una
piattaforma che nasce anche per fare
messaggi vocali fa dire una cosa
fondamentalmente che WhatsApp in realtà
lo usiamo ma non abbiamo ben capito come
si colloca nelle nostre relazioni e
relazioni sociali Cioè non ancora una
sua un'etichetta come dobbiamo usarlo ti
mando il messaggino ti mando il
messaggino e poi serve il messaggio
vocale Ti mando un messaggio vocale e tu
In modo tale che dici Ok mandami
messaggio vocale e poi ti faccio un un
un un un un un un un un una polemica di
20 minuti che poteva essere di risolta
con la telefonata Grazie all'interazione
all'interatività delle telefonia c'è
questo fa capire come in realtà i
messaggi WhatsApp sono
contemporaneamente una nuova forma di
interazione sociale e quindi noi siamo
diventati Cyborg Grazie anche
l'opportunità che le tecnologie mettono
a disposizione
WhatsApp ha fatto in modo di hanno messo
la famosa doppia spunta e nel 2018
ma adesso non ricordo la data quello che
so è che ha tolto la possibilità ha
messo la possibilità di disattivare la
notifica doppia spunta 24 ore dopo
perché aveva creato la famosa questione
hai ricevuto il messaggio visto che la
visualizzato due punti perché non mi ha
risposto risposta Ci sarà un motivo
fra avere un incidente stradale e
rispondere alla tua maledetta doppia
spunta preferisco aspettare un attimo ed
evitare un incidente stradale 24 ore
dopo WhatsApp ha messo la possibilità di
disattivare la doppia spunta Infatti se
voi cercate su Google come fare per
messaggi Google finisce di completare
disattivare la doppia spunta di WhatsApp
perché è una delle informazioni più
ricercate su Google degli ultimi anni
siamo diventati non solo Cyborg ma siamo
diventati post umani nel senso che siamo
sempre persone ma abbiamo bisogno di un
nuovo Umanesimo Cioè dobbiamo
reinscriverci all'interno di un nuovo
Umanesimo Siamo esseri umani potenziati
da tecnologia che questa è una cosa
positiva ma che ancora non controlliamo
completamente credo che ci sia proprio
un girone dell'inferno per i gruppi
WhatsApp delle mamme e dei propri figli
perché è impossibile pensare che questa
cosa non venga
che questa cosa ci consideri Ci
consiglia ancora degli esseri umani Io
sono nei gruppi WhatsApp di mia figlia
che va alle scuole medie È molto spesso
mi viene la voglia di reagire in maniera
poco urbana Ma questo me lo resisto
Allora per dare senso a tutto questo
ragionamento Ci serve una constatazione
e una domanda Cominciamo con la
constatazione volente o nolenti stiamo
assistendo agli ultimi anni del XX
secolo cioè il ventesimo secolo sta
finendo e il ventunesimo secolo sta
prendendo forma Noi ci troviamo in un
crepuscolo in una nuova in una nuova
epoca in cui dobbiamo però decidere da
che parte stare cioè se continuare a
vivere il XXI secolo con i limiti del
ventesimo secolo o prendere di petto le
opportunità che la tecnologia ci ha
messo a disposizione ed evitare di
cercare gattini quando abbiamo
telefonato in tasca ma magari trovare
cose un pochettino più interessanti
nulla vieta continuare a scherzare a
divertirci su Tik Tok Ma magari c'è vita
oltre Tik Tok il ventesimo secolo è
ormai sta finendo però sta finendo in un
modo disordinato Perché sembra mm ci fa
vedere il ventunesimo secolo Ma è ancora
ventesimo secolo facciamo un esempio pan
dei miei globali non si sentiva parlare
il termine pandemia non esisteva più da
anni l'ultima volta che c'è stato il
termine pandemia era legata
fondamentalmente alla influenza spagnola
della Prima Guerra Mondiale 1915-18
invece è tornato un nuovo oggetto sono
tornati i virus che è legato
fondamentalmente al modo con cui siamo
altrettanto il nostro ambiente
pandemie globali È un termine che fa
capire come sta finendo il ventesimo
secolo è il ventunesimo secolo sta
assumendo una strana forma guerre euro
asiatiche si sta spostando l'asse del
mondo come abbiamo già avuto modo di
sentire E in queste guerre era asiatiche
si gioca sempre su un doppio piano
tecnologico e militare quello che vedete
è una foto roiter in cui si vede un un
un soldato dell'esercito ucraino che sta
utilizzando un fucile anti drone cioè un
fucile Fatemelo dire antirobot anti
Terminator per chi è appassionato di
fantascienza un'altra caratteristica
Stanno cominciando emergere dei nuovi
modi per vivere la rete non più
attraverso schermi ma immergendosi in
essa in metà versi si metà versi sono
delle opportunità sì lo sono ma possono
anche essere dei rischi e dei pericoli
come società civile dobbiamo sempre
tenere le antenne ben rizzate ogni volta
che si parla di diritti privacy e
tecnologie digitali e metaversi questi
lo fanno lo sottolineo con molta forza
un'altra caratteristica i soggetti i
soggetti stanno diventando identità
mutanti non siamo più si parla tanto di
non essere non binari e non è una un
vezzo culturale ma perché la tecnologia
Ma anche la sensibilità sociale
contemporanea del ventunesimo secolo fa
capire che noi viviamo in un continuum
di body di essere esseri umani quelli
che vedete sono i fratelli wachowski per
chi non li conoscesse wachowski sono i
fratelli che hanno fatto
Matrix più altri tanti film visionari V
per Vendetta Cloud Atlas e così via
dicendo Vieni qua Ciao che è stata la
prima dei due fratelli a fare un
percorso di transgender Se adesso vi
facessi vedere la foto di entrambi
entrambi sono diventati delle donne
Infatti molti ritengono che la vera la
vera informazione che è nascosta dentro
la trilogia di Matrix non è una guerra
contro le macchine ma un cercare la
propria identità mutante all'interno nel
mondo che ha sempre meno vincoli e poi
non dimentichiamoci che c'è anche sta
cambiando il potere dei popoli Noi siamo
stati sempre abituati a vivere il
ventesimo secolo con un secolo in cui
c'era il potere da un lato e c'è i
popoli che subivano questo potere
dall'altro poteva essere la dittatura
potesse la democrazia ma il potere viene
sempre subito nella contemporaneità le
cose all'interno molto più complicate
anche paesi molto bravi a gestire il
potere come la Cina ha in questo in
queste ultime settimane stanno avendo
dei grossissimi problemi per
confrontarse nei confronti della
popolazione che sta chiedendo di
togliere Finalmente il maledetto
lockdown quelli che vedete è una foto
che rappresenta le manifestazioni della
settimana scorsa che c'ero sono stati
vicino a Wan quindi fondamentalmente
Questa è la constatazione il ventesimo
secolo è finito e sta finendo in un
mondo strano quello che ci dobbiamo
chiedere a questo punto è
abbiamo davvero il coraggio di vivere il
ventunesimo secolo non è più una
questione di avere la tecnologia non
averla vivere in un mondo pandemico non
viverlo vive in un ambiente sempre più
mutante e mutageno oppure non vivere c'è
la questione abbiamo il coraggio di
dimenticare il tipo di umanità che siamo
stati e abbracciare il tipo che
l'umanità che dobbiamo diventare non è
chiaro che diventiamo dei Cyborg ma
sicuramente cominciare ad avere un po'
più di rispetto nei confronti delle
soggettività altre è un nostro preciso
dovere morale e vi ringrazio della
vostra attenzione
[Applauso]